Oh yo we got big news
yo what's that kim jeong-hoon might be
dead brah I know brah
I'm gonna miss some ambiance at you yeah
I was thinking about yeah I was thinking
about today because like he might be the
best worst leader oh he's up there in he
worse in Saddam probably right no so
that's what I'm trying to say he's like
I know we look at him and he's the bad
guy and all this kind of stuff but like
how many people has he really killed we
don't know but that's the thing we don't
know okay right like we shouldn't rush
to judgment is what you leave you should
rush to judgment like we feel bad
because they don't have like you know CD
players and [ __ ] like that or they don't
have like modern technology but if
you've never had it you don't miss it if
you've never had a big meal you don't
know a real full three-piece you know I
mean the seas get a piece of the piece
mmm that's what your stomach is used to
that's what I'm saying it's like what
are they really missing out like what
culture like they talk about this all
the time saying are you they don't have
movies then are they it's like what
they're just remaking all the movie if
they had the old movies they saw the
original Ghostbusters they saw probably
fast and furious one you know I feel
like I really feel like on some level
he's misunderstood and he's not that bad
he's not like bombing other countries he
says he's gonna do he never does it all
right
like who are we really to judge Kim Jong
we probably killed way more people than
Kim Jong hoon and he just kills his own
interesting point
so what's worse yeah killing your own or
doing the us [ __ ] and killing a lot of
prosper you have the right to kill your
own don't you
that's them if that's the rules of your
country listen don't we have the right
to kill her on what what's the rule
called
that fountain Death Valley we kill our
own okay you got the right to kill your
own okay dude think about it yeah we
kill our own is [ __ ] that when you go
kill
when else because you're killing them
right maybe not breaking the rules of
their land you know that we might be
more [ __ ] up other countries might be
more [ __ ] up you have the right to
kill your own we kill our own if some
dudes out there raping and we kill them
everybody's like not I was good
yeah there's countries like yours where
that's okay I was like what's the deal
everybody got their own rules and
everybody got their own rules yeah how's
somebody else parents these kids you
can't that's what America is we're
literally like the [ __ ] white lady
that walks up to the Puerto Rican girl
like spanked her son of the son you two
kids right Kim Jong who's like mind your
[ __ ] business before I blow you up
yeah but he doesn't do it cuz he's [ __ ]
yep what he a decent guy he's what do
you think about it in terms of leaders
in the world right he's probably got the
least amount of bodies he definitely got
the least amount of bodies there aren't
his own oh he's up there he's like you
know hey man it's mother Teresa oon
mother Teresa dude honestly in terms of
the amount of people mother Teresa
killed and Kim jong-un killed outside of
his own outside of his own country not
that different I would say the same I
would say if anything maybe Mother
Teresa killed more people she was
probably going around she might have had
like a call for something like that
somebody got a call City immune system
they died Kim Jong not travel yeah yeah
I'm leaving he's not leaving a country
baby everything's coming to him Dennis
Rodman coming to him he was on the last
dance before everyone was he not yeah
yeah yeah that's it you're right he's
shooting bombs in the air whatever that
you know how much Asians love fireworks
I think a lot of times these people are
completely misunderstood they don't have
a Chinatown where you can get the
fireworks you got to get the fireworks
from the [ __ ] military so that's all
he got that's all he got
there's no Chinese allowed in to make a
Chinatown think about this is she is kim
jeong-hoon that bad when you really want
to consider global leaders is he that
bad hey
man you know he's Sweden to the rest of
the country or Switzerland what's in
neutral in Switzerland Switzerland
Switzerland
he's just Switzerland he's minding his
own business blowing his own rockets
into his own water
maybe Switzerland killing a lot of their
own people and we don't know about it
and we don't even ask is there like
we're neutral were neutral yeah we even
know what's going on there where we got
no clue no clue what's going on in
Switzerland but we don't judge the Prime
Minister of Switzerland maybe he's
racism maybe it is wait what we just
don't erase thank you listen he Asian
and judging here maybe Switzerland doing
the same thing but they're white but
they got white privilege that's it
I'm just trying to flip the liberal
logic on him you might be right about
this hey let's rock with it what is
Switzerland sweat a we ready for it yeah
always Kim Jong never said he was
neutral during [ __ ] real talk
Switzerland has killed more people yeah
hey you might say Kim jong-un is having
atrocities on his own people who lets
atrocities happen to others or other
people Switzerland Switzerland [ __ ] this
North Korea was probably started because
they're like we know the atrocities
happen to our people yeah we gotta start
a new career right yeah there's
something to this
oh if kim jungeun was the leader of
switzerland he could do some great
things
real talk I'm being serious
hey if you tired of going to war as US
and Stefan the problems that aren't your
own and intervening and everybody else's
[ __ ] you know will be a great president
Kim Jong Oh Oh baby oh no think about it
this guy he's a legend bro he's a legend
and honestly I look we really need to
look into this I hope he doesn't die
people are saying he's dead already
no Nessa South Korea yeah why South
Korea's reporting this but they said if
he errs broke yeah they hate us cause
they ain't us so they're saying he's
healthy though huh he's healthy though
this
results operas and he's healthy I heard
the reports are that he's brain-dead
oh yeah yeah and that being said I don't
think that should be a requirement to
lead no I mean that who's more
brain-dead right now Joe Biden Kim
jong-eun it's not far
it's not far there we go it's not far
it's just like a weekend at Bernie's
situation that's it a weekend we gonna
jog ease something severely
misunderstood about kim jeong-hoon
I really do severely severely
misunderstood you should be allowed to
spank your kids we know the daddy of a
nation sometimes you gotta spank your
kids but can you spank someone else's
kids
no it's disrespectful you would never
now if someone told you hey we don't
like the way you spank your kids would
you add some nuclear weapon would
threaten I'd be like I spanked the [ __ ]
out of your kids how about that don't
let me spring my kids [ __ ]
you might be the most American
[ __ ] out there can I be honest
with you in the way that he operates
that's why Trump called him rocket boy
it was a compliment was it cover the
bombs person in the air me about yah he
listened to the national anthem bro I'm
telling you we could learn something
from Kim Jong oh yeah
gave his life the man gave his life so
are you saying it's so Asian Games Laver
dude for real yeah the guy gave his
[ __ ] life mess so the report is that
what's the official report I was in
grave danger after surgery so the real
question is what surgery what surgery
did he get surgery penis enlargement you
think his penis enlargement gotta be I
thought it was putting the folds on
their eyelids you know how he's into
that [ __ ] I thought he was getting that
brazilian butt-lift
y al you suck the fat out the stomach
and then make him his ass more
attractive for Rodman interesting
interests as Rotman isn't he into the
lady boys huh isn't Robin into [ __ ] I
think Robin would be a [ __ ] he was in
the know how that world works I don't
buy this [ __ ] one bit I'll be honest I
think I know what happened oh that's not
what I think I think I know saying I'll
be honest like you saying some different
[ __ ] than you normally I think I know
what happened the only difference is the
words I think oh god I'll be even more
honest and I was just about to be
increase honesty by at least one decibel
right now okay I think we know he's a
big basketball fan yes he not oh yeah
what do you think he was doing Sunday
watching the last [ __ ] dance
for his boy [ __ ] wife was probably
yapping the [ __ ] off it's got miss a
very important part you know he can't
rewind he's in North Korea ain't got
[ __ ] rewind right heart attack
heart attack yep straight to the
hospital
mm-hmm that's what he's recovering from
and he probably like look just tell
everybody I'm dead for ten weeks I got
ten episodes this show to get through
five weeks maybe even as soon as the
rodman episode is over you'll start
hearing little reports that he's
recovering a miracle recovery we need to
start selling some bands what wound do
cuz that is genius
this guy's a [ __ ] genius
[Applause]